March 1981 25 year-old John Hinckley has
just shot President Ronald Reagan and
three others his motive to impress
Hollywood actress Jodie Foster by
imitating the actions of a character
played by her co-star Robert DeNiro in
the film taxi driver a year later a jury
found him not guilty by reason of
insanity
they said he needed treatment not a
lifetime behind bars that verdict caused
widespread dismay and now Inc he may
soon be free on Wednesday a court will
start to consider if he should be
released from the mental hospital way
he's been treated for over three decades
Hinckley's already experienced some
freedom and now he can stay for up to 17
days per month with his mother in
Virginia his lawyers and doctors have
testified that Hinckley has become a low
dangerous but prosecutors and the
American public have consistently
opposed his release raising the question
after being detained for 34 years is
truly ready for life on the outside skip
more on those from Washington DC del
quentin Wilber who's journalist and
author orbit will hide down the near
assassination of Ronald Reagan factor
joining us on Sky News tonight now
you've followed this very closely for a
number of years of course who got these
hearings starting on Wednesday how
likely is it after all these years that
he gets total freedom you know that's a
really interesting question I think that
we've tracked this case and the
progression of Hinkley's freedoms going
back to 2006 that's when a federal judge
here who weighs this issue first gave
him more freedom from st. Elizabeth's
Hospital where you know as you said he's
been confined since 1982 when he was
found not guilty by reason of insanity
at each step in the judicial process st.
Elizabeth's has come forward with
Hinkley's attorneys and said he needs a
bit more freedom he needs a more time at
home he needs to be able to drive a car
we need to reintegrate him into society
because that is the charge of the
hospital with all their patients and
they've been doing that federal
prosecutors in a handle said hey wait a
minute no no he's not ready and in each
step they have fought a lot of those
motions and those arguments by the other
side
over time we've gone from 10-day visits
to 17 day visits and now the hospital
has again put forward a petition it's
under seal we don't know what they're
going to ask for we presume they're
going to ask for more than they did last
time which was 24 days stays so they
could ask for you know complete
convalescent leave like we've washed our
hands with them he's done send them to
Williamsburg forever or it could be more
like the conditional release that we've
seen recently where they go you know we
would like to transfer even more of his
care to psyche at psychiatrist and
facilities in Williamsburg where he
lives with his mother most of the time
now 17 days a month as you noted he's
done the 12 of these visits since the
last order back in 2013 and we'd like to
do more of that but maybe it's a
month-long visit maybe it's a two-month
long visit we don't know we don't know
yet prosecutors historically have fought
this and they've raised questions one
the standard Hinkley's judge under is
the danger to himself or others and the
hospital says no prosecutors say yes I
mean how can a guy he has all these
issues at the hospital all these
personal problems you know he's he's
lied on plate been deceitful how do we
trust him a man who shot the president
severely wounded Jim Brady the press
secretary Jim Brady died last year his
death ruled a homicide because of
Hinkley's bullet that eventually killed
him and Sarah Brady his wife just died
so you know this is a very complicated
issue that the judge is going to have to
untangle not just after one day of
hearings we're going to hear from
psychiatric witnesses we're going to
hear from you know maybe hear from him
please family and others over the course
of several days and the judge will weigh
this and write an order an opinion
either deny granting it you know kind of
finding his own way to figure out how to
make this work you know months from now
and of course on top of that we have
public opinion as well don't we because
it was hugely controversial when that
verdict was delivered what over thirty
four years ago that that plea of
insanity was accepted that changed the
way wasn't it thatis and he was actually
viewed as a justification and what kind
of all will that play you know I think
this judge has been pretty you know he
has a lifetime appointment I don't I
can't see him really caring one way or
another one
public opinion says I think that you
know he's definitely taking these
stances you know 17 days a month in
please without direct hospital
supervision in Williamsburg
I mean it's he is so he's already taken
those steps I think you're right about
public opinion it's really interesting
you know that if John Hinckley did this
today he'd be convicted because after
the shooting the standard of proof
changed Hinckley raised the defense of
insanity by reason of insanity in 1982
and it was incumbent upon the government
the prosecutors to prove no he was
saying now it's flipped and he won't
think he would get through it today I
think John Hinckley would spend the rest
of his life in bars interestingly enough
if he had been convicted back then he
probably already be released today
so he's been confined longer than he
would have if convicted today be
confined for life interesting for del
Quentin will be expected talk she passed
ons is grainy tonight